vladimir putin's once again threatened
to use nuclear force if any other nation
intervenes in the ukraine war and even
russian state television is now telling
viewers a nuclear war is probable so let
me bring in now british british special
forces war hero at middleton and great
to see you thanks for coming to the
studio to have you here thanks for
having me start with the ukraine wall
what's your gut feeling here my feeling
about putin is he knows that he's got us
over a barrel that he's got this big
nuclear arsenal and all he has to do is
wave it at us and we all run a mile that
goes against every instinct that i've
ever had about dealing with a genocidal
maniac
what's your view though obviously it's
complicated obviously it's yeah it's got
risk but what do we do about this guy
well when you've got someone barking as
much as putin about nuclear weapons
first of all you ask yourself two
questions one does he have that
capability and two is he has he got the
minerals has he got the balls to use
that capability i'd say no and third i
would say so don't say what would be his
motivation to start a war that would
lead to the immediate destruction of
himself
and his own country it would be the next
world war three basically what he's done
he's uh he's gone into ukraine
that they're amazing people their
fighting force is holding the fort at
the moment you know don't think that the
russians are going in there and having
an easy time because they're certainly
not i know people who are on the ground
in ukraine and um you know they're
they're quite happy at the moment
actually because they're actually i
think they're genuinely holding them
they think they can generally beat them
but putin can be in this for the long
term we've seen his track record in
these situations he might be doing this
just for years the guy's unstable it's
clear to see when i saw his first
interview with putin i saw how unstable
he was and i thought to myself wow this
guy's got potential to do something
crazy but the amount of barking that
he's doing and the amount of uh sort of
talking that he's doing especially about
nuclear deterrence and nuclear weapons
i think that he's just he's he's that
he's at his wit's end now and now he's
trying to
the divert people by by making the noise
of that he's got if he invaded a nato
country we would be morally compelled to
get involved i don't see a lot of moral
difference between
that and what's happening in ukraine
other than ukraine is not a member of
nato yet you know i just feel do we not
at some point have a moral duty to get
involved with conventional weapons given
nato is so powerful well what we've got
to realize is not a game of poker you
know people are saying how is he
bluffing should we go in there it's it's
more sensitive than that if we go in
there it's going to cost
millions more lives it's going to start
world war iii let's be honest um we
either look at the situation and go
right do we now come together as nato
and
strike first or do we hold back and and
see what putin's up to but
it's it's a catch-22 it's one of those
where if if nuclear weapons are involved
then you know it's world war three we
should be able to use the nuclear
capability as a protective shield to
genocide which is what's going on it's
supposed supposed to be mutually assured
destruction system when neither side
would ever use it both sides have it you
know
nato and russia both have it but we both
understand what capability
if he keeps saying if you do anything
i'll use it that's the misuse of the
nuclear deterrent isn't it yeah but the
more time he he gives like that the the
more we think to ourselves right it's
it's just a bluff he's just he's just
that's my gun
but also he can't he can't have the the
liberty of the freedom to keep doing
that no there's something has to be done
about it you know that's what i said it
has to be a time scale where people
where we say as nato as the uk we say
right enough is enough this is when we
need to strike or this is the the the
action that we need to take uh i agree i
know i believe we're reaching that point
pretty quickly you talked about the
ukrainian spirit of the people they are
quite extraordinary and it really
reminds me i think of what i think is
becoming a sort of rarity in our society
certainly here and you see it in america
you see it in australia around the world
now where there's almost a premium on
not having resilience or mental strength
everyone talks all the time about mental
weakness in a way and
society seems to me to have gone a bit
soft yeah what do you think is going on
here and where do we how can we get the
kind of spirit you see the ukrainians
showing well it's the whole wokeness
isn't it it's sort of taken over it's
it's everything's uh pampy-pampy
feelings and emotions and ultimately
it's about facts you know it's
especially with ukraine the fact is your
country has been invaded you have to now
you know
um deep deep into that psychological
reserve and go right listen this has
happened now we need to we need to you
know all come together and we need to
stay resilient and we need to fight back
or those that have been forced the
children women that have been forced to
especially children i've talked about
this to my wife when i say about the
children been forced to understand about
war you know these should be innocent
children are going about their everyday
lives going to school learning growing
growing up and understanding who they
are they're having to learn about war
from the young age of five so i think we
should be i would love to see people
like you going into schools teaching
kids about perspective about resilience
about mental strength i don't see any of
that the whole debate is skewed towards
almost almost celebrating weakness
turning everyone into victims everyone's
complaining about the healthy
communities
and they go on instagram and all this
kind of thing i want to show you a
little clip this this is the opposite in
a way this is what's given me hope for
the future it's a young eight-year-old
kid called jack and he plays at sember a
famous rugby school in the north of
england this is him when he one of his
little teammates was upset jack decided
to grasp the metal look at this
it's okay everyone's older than everyone
you don't have to tackle don't listen to
me nobody listens to me trust me look at
me look at me bob i'm the shortest kid
here listen it doesn't matter who you
are it doesn't matter if you're short
you're young it doesn't matter if you're
taller it doesn't matter if you fight it
doesn't matter you thought
well you are a brilliant rugby player
you understand that you're insane you
are actually insane for your way
good on jack you know when i see that i
think that's the spirit
right don't just quit don't just lie on
the floor i talked to tyson furiously
about rocky balboa it's not about many
times you get knocked over it's how many
times in life you can get back up and
keep moving forward and keep punching
that's what resilience is all about but
in schools they don't teach that now you
know the healthy competition where no
one is about participating no one's
first no one second no one's third it's
like you know we want to be winners we
are a nation of winners you know that
kid is the biggest hype guys you have a
great start a great start came out the
other day the oscar winners who win
oscars live on average about five or six
years longer and they researched a
thousand oscar winners nominees the
nominees who lost right which was final
proof to me but no one wants to lose
winning actually makes you live longer
no one wants the silver or bronze medal
with everything i don't know
you know i must debate every olympics
yeah it celebrates losing but why why is
there a silver and gold medal should be
um silver and bronze medal should be a
gold medal one
or nothing i totally agree with it you
know the world's gone the world does
need to toughen up and and all
seriousness with ukraine it's it's it's
a sad state of affairs and it's it's
about time that we realize that that the
facts are
we need resilience we need to be strong
we need to you know when everything is
crumbling around us like it is the with
you so i hope it gives people something
else these ukrainian people are showing
such unbelievable courage and resilience
and inspiring inspiring personal
behavior when everybody else is
squealing about stuff it just doesn't
matter um i've got to leave it because
there's a genuine former olympic gold
medalist ready for me this is caitlyn
jenner let's do it we won the olympic
gold decathlon medal for the united
states uh before becoming the most
famous trans woman in the world so i'll
talk to her in a moment
great to see you uh i know you got
ridiculously cancelled off your show in
the uk that show has never been the same
since you've got onto better things so
great to see you thank you very much
peace all the best